it's morning on Mars the Sun is 140
million miles away but strong enough to
send current flowing through the solar
panels of the rover called opportunity
waking it up for another day of work
opportunity got off to a quick start
landing in January 2004 after a
seven-month journey to Mars touching
down in a region called Meridiani Planum
it bounced across the plane in its
airbag cocoon by chance it rolled into a
shallow crater
at JPL they waited for the first
pictures as opportunity emerged from its
protective shell we open our eyes and
there's this astounding outcrop a
layered bedrock right in front of the
vehicle Mars has been a frigid desert
for billions of years
but satellite images suggest that liquid
water once flowed across the surface
from orbit though it's hard to tell
whether it was an environment that could
have supported life how much water was
there what was its chemistry suppose you
were a microbe would you have liked that
place or not if so why the rover's are
filled geologists designed to read clues
to the environment of early Mars
preserved in the rocks and minerals each
has a toolkit on its robotic arm to
grind off the weathered surface of rocks
and analyze their composition
they see the world in three dimensions
with four pairs of stereo cameras
opportunity goes to work looking for
evidence of ancient water and over a few
weeks makes a series of startling
discoveries it was like being inside
this bizarre Martian mystery novel where
every soul or two you'd get a new clue
handed to you
first-come tiny spheres the size of B
B's littering the ground and embedded in
the outcrop like blueberries in a muffin
there was such a surprise what the heck
were those things the instruments find
that they're made of an iron mineral
called hematite on earth had formed
spheres like these in water soaked rocks
like pearls and oysters
and finally evidence of ripples created
by water flowing across the surface
frozen in time as the sand turned to
stone the clues add up to a place where
salty water virtually sulfuric acid once
soaked the ground and sometimes flowed
across the surface on earth microbial
life can thrive in places like this
there wasn't a single one of us who
expected what we found anybody tells you
so lying it was a new Mars
if opportunity's mission had ended here
it would have been a great success but
now the rover heads for a bigger deeper
crater nearby which could expose even
more bedrock as we went deeper the
chemistry and the texture of the rocks
changed dramatically in a way that
indicated to us that the deeper rocks
had been soaked in water for a long
period of time
it now appears that the water at
Meridiani may have lasted hundreds of
thousands if not millions of years a
gamble to go into the crater definitely
paid off scientifically it really really
improved our understanding of what we
were dealing with here you know at this
point every day is a gift we just push
the vehicles as hard as we can enjoy
them while we got them and someday
they're gonna die and I don't know when
however this adventure ends their legacy
is assured they've returned hundreds of
thousands of images enough data on
Martian water history to keep scientists
busy for decades and their most
important work may be yet to come